à la réunion quand on parle de tambour
on fait souvent référence à cet
instrument de grand diamètre fréquemment
dressées en peau de chèvre le tambour
malbar les temps voit l'arrivée avec les
engagés indiens
c'est à dire que les médias n'était
l'origine de tamines hadoop donc si
aussi calcutta donc en arriver là mais
le tambour parce que tout ça a été un
instrument de deux connexions salle
instruments ou en frappant dit s'il peut
rassembler les gens
on n'est qu'en étant un bol battez de
l'univers autour donc c'est premièrement
le temps beauté si amazon pour annoncer
les événements culturels pour notre hôte
les fêtes les mariages et aussi la mort
philippe et président de l'association
tambours sacrés de la réunion dont le
but est de promouvoir la pratique du
tambour malbar mais pas seulement no 96
on l'a créé le couple tombe au sacré et
en créant le groupe tango sacré une
langage amont sur colette histoire
transmettent effet à jouer quand il a
recommencé avec cette activité-là
l'apathique fédéraux c'est la novation
bonne son ami bonne version est bonne
mais il n'est pas question est ce que
c'est en angola que la touche est
utilisé des chapelles est-ce qu'il peut
jouer un autre côté des anciens 10 est
en mauvais terme or l'essentiel ce que
sogeti donc là dit oui la seule solution
est de monaco ce que ça coûterait de la
chapelle où joue pas demain aux patients
d'un festival et je passerai du profane
donc nous tous que nous et avec bernard
maps et des morceaux qu on leur crée ses
des morceaux culturel la chance qu'on a
c'est que les anciens la pmi à nous
d'apprendre comment fabrique-t-on
les trois instruments principaux
utilisés dans le groupe tambours sacrés
sont le mans long le sact y est le
tambour malbar des temps pour fabriquer
par les joueurs eux-mêmes qui nie nous
explique la vente ou faux la matière
première c'est à dire la peau on a tous
peur voire trois qualités peut soit la
peau cf soit la prochaine soit la peau
de bouc
après il faut le siècle et le valais
rond et ficelles et après
traditionnellement les anciens salaires
montano s'était fait la colle avec la
farine
et pour l'occasion une partie de la
troupe s'est rassemblée pour une courte
démonstration chez les parents d'aymeric
jeunes joueurs du groupe tambours sacrés
et ben ils savent à la chapelle est égal
ou tomates et les imiter brut a provoqué
fait pareil si longtemps beau simon
passe on est dans la troupe
on compte aussi des femmes ce qui n'est
pas autorisé dans les temples justin
fait partie du groupe depuis quatre ans
comme à l'arrivée m'avait jamais fait en
bois à prendre la voie du début jusqu à
commenter nier comment chauffer en plus
cela signifie donc est le garçon comme à
l'arrivée il fait 4 me jouer donc mais
c'est un peu au jour le jour mais c'est
vrai qu'à chaque fois nous à
l'entraînement nous apprend avec nous la
pintade religieux vous verrez c'est
culturel n'importe qui il veut jouer
tambours sacrés gary dû jouer pendant
sept ans voilà c'est un tombeau qui
porte en lui toute l'histoire de ses
ancêtres nous prend conscience que ces
tambours qu on utilise ici en un appui
avec ses tambours la bonne marmaille la
découvre le monde elle a vu que le monde
les pam il ya que la réunion
mixité parité voyages et découvertes
une évolution culturelle réussie est
mise en avant par le groupe tambours
sacrés de la réunion si autrefois la
foule s'approcher au son du tambour
c'est maintenant au tour du tambour
d'aller vers les foules à travers le
monde
git